a quick note that this episode contains
some adult language so
you've been warned and if that intrigues
you welcome
[Music]
it's fair to say that adolescence is an
awkward time for most people that's fair
i did a movie called he's just not that
into you and um it had a what is known
in the business as a star-studded cast
drew barrymore and jennifer aniston and
justin long ryan
ben affleck to promote the movie we all
went on one of those big shows i forget
which one and uh they showed our high
school yearbook photos and when it got
to my picture all of the women who were
all doing press together burst out into
laughter fits of laughter all of them
these beautiful people laughing at me
mocking me
it was like a nightmare and it brought
me right back to that high school
experience and you know the lesson that
i'm always learning is that we never
really leave high school psychologically
life could be a dream
[Music]
from wondering this is life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
i'm here with my brother christian hello
and before we get into it we just want
to thank everyone for listening and we
appreciate all of your feedback too so
uh if if you have a desire to comment uh
even the negative stuff the constructive
criticism is really helpful it's a
learning process so uh it's been helpful
we don't know what we're doing yeah this
is we have no business doing this i want
to get back to this picture for a second
yeah i have uh speaking i have a little
more to say about this picture speaking
of criticism the day the music died
the day of the day i'll never forget
it's like
when i saw your senior photo in high
school a long long time ago
i was picking you up for a mattress oh
man in high school you were a senior and
i was a freshman and you drove me to
school every day
thank you for that i mean he signed 200
yeah really shitty old car but i thought
i thought i was cool we went to an
all-boys school and they called you
schlong
is your nickname i don't think there's
anything specific about your penis but
it was just low-hanging fruit so to
speak yeah
jj schlong
and they called me little schlong
because i was a freshman you were a
senior oh well that sucks and again not
because of the genitalia it's not
i remember uh after school that day you
you were sort of bummed out
and you handed me
the yearbook you said that the yearbook
came out today and
and you didn't say anything we sort of
sighed you're sort of heavy about it and
you handed it to me and i opened it up
and
i remember it so clearly because i don't
think i've ever
laughed so hard in my life
i started to panic a little bit because
i was laughing so hard that's how hard i
was laughing it was so subtly
unattractive
you know as since then i've tried to i'm
really proud of my driver's license
photo i tried to make my eyes go a
little crossed and remember when the guy
who took it at the dmv he said uh
you won't you want to do another one and
i look back at him with like crossed
eyes again and i was like why
and he was like never mind
maybe it's my version of trying to take
the power back and like now i'm gonna
you know try to be goofy um but at the
time i have to tell you that i was not
trying to be goofy i was trying to smile
but i was so self-conscious that this is
what happened to my face so speaking of
unattractive embarrassing photos
uh our guest today
has probably never taken one exactly our
guest today is of course the hideous
olivia wilde olivia is an actress
producer
director now many hats wears many hats
she is also so down to earth and easy
it's a really interesting combination
and it's in one person yeah olivia's a
great actress everyone knows uh but
she's also an incredible director and uh
this is something that i've known for a
long time
because i did uh a short film that she
made her first her directorial debut uh
it was called free hugs and you can
watch it on on youtube but we made that
about eight or nine years ago so i'm a
little ahead of the curve in terms of
knowing that olivia is an incredible
director but everyone is going to be
able to discover that uh this this
weekend when her movie book smart comes
out
this is her first feature film that
she's made and it's so good that she can
already be called an accomplished
director it's starring two young women
uh caitlyn deiver and beanie feldstein
who we've known for many years she's
jonah hill's younger sister in fact
we've known beanie for so long that we
were at beanie's bat mitzvah we saw
beanie become a woman not in a in
a more religious way yes in a strictly
religious way and olivia also so
perfectly captures beanie's essence in
the movie and uses it to great effect um
book smart was is so good such a great
high school movie um and olivia's
captured that feeling that awkwardness
that excitement that um that the fear of
high school uh so perfectly and so
profoundly and hysterically i am so
proud of her and uh i can't wait to to
talk to her about it and i'm also just
so grateful that uh she was willing to
come on and we're gonna get into it with
olivia
about book smart and many other things
right after this
uh what the this is so weird it's
weird to catch okay so we're gonna
really catch up but this should actually
be this should be the theme of your
podcast you should see you should only
have friends you haven't seen in like
five years yeah and then record catching
up
um you're going to new york after this
you're going to do a whole we're here
until like mid july and then i got to
figure out what to do next wow you need
a job well yeah yeah good luck
do you remember the last time you really
worried about getting a job yeah like
every day right
i still i mean it does does that ever go
away
i don't know but you're also in like a
great place right you gotta feel good
you have to feel more confident about
getting a job i do but it's interesting
because like as an actor you can do
several movies a year you can do you can
kind of spread yourself then you can
jump in and out like i now i like in
like acting is dating directing is like
marriage like several
marriages that i guess like end
unsuccessfully
what would you know about that
like it's weird but it's like
because you're because the time comes
because the time commitment i mean you
are fully committed to one project for
two years when you direct so it's a
scarier to choose what to do like a
marriage you gotta there's you've gotta
eventually you will have it will pass
and you'll go do something else i mean
the marriage uh metaphor is getting real
rocky
i guess it's more like because
yeah relationship versus like just like
skimming the surface and around
acting is just around just
hooking up
well who is the favorite what's your
favorite hookup
of all my acting yeah
i know it's a tough i you know what you
know what i think it is drinking buddies
oh yeah i bet it seemed like it it was
because it's always the last one you
would expect also is the one that like
my agents had zero awareness up i
remember when i i got the job on my own
because they probably paid nothing it
paid nothing they did they this is how
like a sign that i was at the wrong
agency they they didn't even know where
i was i was in chicago filming it and
they called me and asked me to go do
something in new york and i was like no
i'm i'm in i'm in chicago remember i'm
making that that improvised movie and
they were like what what is it and i was
like oh i just care about it so much
it's just this little labor of love and
they're like okay when is it over i'm
like just a couple weeks and then it
ended up being
better and like more successful than
like most of what i've done and it
showed such a different side a side of
you that like i had seen yes you were
like it was like the real yeah it was
the first time i took
some sort of creative ownership of
something and i think that's why it
feels like a game changer for me because
it made me think like maybe i am okay at
this and maybe i could
probably give you that behind the camera
because
it was a script we essentially all wrote
together because we improvised it yeah
and so when i realized like wait
maybe i can kind of construct a scene
i had never really considered that to be
a skill and i thought well we did make
this work so maybe i could do it again
so good and you think like well it
didn't require in terms of like crew and
you had up until then you had been on
these huge movies in fact hadn't you
just done cowboys
cowboys and aliens
had been a couple years before but there
was
been a lot of like big things yeah so
you see the amount of like just the the
machines that go in just the amount
exactly manpower and then like and then
this little thing that just has its
heart in the right place with people
just doing it for the right reasons yeah
it's just like the rule of thumb over
and over again well that's how your
movie your movie had elements of both
those things i i think uh yes it had it
felt like a labor did you watch it yes
yeah i don't want to talk about it so
it's well well wait till you hear what i
thought about it no i loved it it's so
good uh
i i wanted to wait to tell you in person
i was so proud of you i i'm gonna get
i'm getting a little teary cause you
gotta cry well uh i did you first i did
you're sure yes it was the first thing
that's what i was gonna say it was um it
was called free hugs yes it was i
rewatched it the other day and it's
really good
you know what's funny it
that is a program by the way should
still exist it was called glamour real
moments they paid like a lot of money
yeah you had a budget for
new directors all actresses i mean
not nude right i just want to clarify
actors that would have made it really
something a lot of money actresses who
were paid to be nude and also directly
yes
yeah female filmmaker friday it was it
was a cool thing because what they did
is they kind of set up the
the logistics
of make of the kind of production so
people who had no experience in that
could make their first film without the
fear of like but how do i prep a film
they kind of did a lot of the legwork
and the only requirement was that you
had to base your film on a glamour
reader's short story and that was the
restriction and so you got to write it
then i wrote it based on this short
story and it was you know so in some
ways it was limiting because it was like
you have to kind of target it in this
direction but
mine was very very um it was a departure
it was yeah you expanded it i expanded
and but i heard you say that you didn't
you want you were the thing that you
wanted to direct your first feature you
wanted to write you felt like you should
be writing thought i should write my
first feature so what what was it about
the story that you thought like oh this
is this is what this is why i want to
marry for a couple years
this is what i want to get involved with
i think it was
the realization that you don't
necessarily have to write it to to have
real creative ownership and to make it
your own and to personalize it i think i
realized like wait
as actors we personalize roles we didn't
necessarily write for ourselves so as
directors it's a similar process you can
read some a piece of material and think
okay this is a blueprint and
this is the structure and a story i like
but i'm now going to infuse it with
everything that makes me unique and it
will become
my story a version of what you do as an
actor i guess exactly i think it is more
similar than people realize but for me
on booksmart
i got the original script
and jessica album at gloria sanchez she
and i were driving around town pitching
a comedy series that our friend nora
kirkpatrick had written
and
it was a bonker series and kind of
through the process of it jess learned a
little bit about me and kind of the way
i approach things and she was like man
you really need to direct a feature and
i was like oh that's the dream and i was
doing music videos at the time i
directed an edward sharp video and i
just finished doing a chili peppers
video oh wow
there were the red hot ones the red hot
ones with your doppelganger yeah
and i
loved it and i was like oh wait i'm
happiest on set actually on free hugs
i remember jacqueline who's in who's the
star
she said to me and she'd known me for
years she's like i've never seen you so
happy as when you're directing you
see you yeah i was lit up i think it was
just like oh wait i have a confidence in
this that i just never truly had as an
actor
and that continued on the music videos i
mean i felt so good and i was not
intimidated by the process i just loved
every element of it and so i was like
yes that is what i need to find for
myself what will be the project that
will be the first feature and jess was
like you should read book smart
2009 um emily halpern and sarah haskins
wrote book smart it was on the blacklist
it it wavered a bit it was at fox it
never made it to production
it was at annapurna and susanna fogle
did a pass
and at that point anna perna attached
caitlyn deaver
but it kind of got stuck in in pre sort
of development hell and it never made it
to production so i was stunned that you
didn't cast her only because you guys
have such a similar oh yeah quality your
voice your voices are
that's very nice because i love her
voice
she can sing now and i can't but
you've only heard me sing like when very
drunk yes you're great i was also very
drunk
it's not fair i can't but i really loved
that caitlyn was attached it was one of
the reasons that i was like whoa i want
to know what this is all about so i read
it and i was like ugh this is such a
good idea at that point you know the the
kernel of the story was there it was
about two best friends who were very
smart and were kind of unapologetic
about their intelligence there was
almost like a gangster attitude towards
their nerdiness they weren't trying to
assimilate they didn't care about
becoming popular it was just like we're
so smart and
we love each other so intensely and that
appealed to you why did did you feel
that way in high school did you ha did
you i felt
in high school that it was i i didn't
have the instinct to
fit in
and i thought so many high school movies
were about fitting in yeah and i thought
there needs to be one that it's that's
not the point it's not about like
they're happy on the outskirts exactly
as were the guys in super bad kind of i
mean although they wanted to go to the
park
it's interesting because that was all
about like the fulfillment that came
from hooking up because that represented
something more existential but their
plan in that story was just to
have that sexual experience it would
make them feel like men yeah and book
smart i thought that we could make this
kind of deeper and broader in a way and
kind of flesh out an ensemble because
like i love movies like fast times
yeah an opportunity to have a really
rich ensemble and you have the don
phillips of our day in allison jones who
cast this right allison did a lot of
judd's movies right she did judge movies
movies she i mean she did freaks and
geeks everything everything uh but truly
the generations of comedic ensembles
that are so iconic um uh super bad prize
maids
veep freaks and geeks yeah the list just
look her up
uh i should have ron the office you
should have her on yeah she's seen it
all so i took okay so i pitched on i
pitched annapurna based on the 2014
draft and i was like please hire me you
have no reason to hire me but i'm going
to convince you to hire me based on this
deck that i have
that had
caitlyn deaver as amy and beanie
falcinos molly i also had billy lord on
there as gigi i said let me make this
movie with this cast with this music
with these kind of out-of-the-box weird
ideas that i think we could put in here
and it needs a rewrite it just needs to
be updated because so many scripts like
that's the process especially a high
school school i mean high school is
changing so rapidly high school culture
so by 2017 which is i pitched in 2016 i
was like we've already come a long way
since 2014. so then i got to hire katie
silverman who is extraordinary
she is such an awesome writer and she's
so fast
that in four months
we rewrote the entire script and it was
like a completely different movie wow
wow and to their credit annapurna was
down with that and very supportive
and then we got to start developing the
actual
movie and casting and that was the dream
because my first job in this business
was the casting assistant i know at
mally finn's valley finn so mally finn i
don't want to say anything disparaging
because she did incredible she was tough
she was a tough lady and i remember
being in the middle of an audition so
she cast like all the john grisham movie
it was always intimidating going to her
office because they were like
posters of like you know gene hackman
movie and like and she had discovered a
lot of brad renfrow brad renfrow um
russell crowe right um i mean angelina
she was like
we used to watch all the in the downtime
i'd watch all the audition tapes the
like iconic audition times sam rockwell
you saw sam's for the green mile it's
one of the most genius do you know the
story about his audition no okay i have
to say this because his legendary i
would have asked him but it was uh so
basically when i was working there
lowest of the low grunt work like bring
you your coffee i brought the actors
water
and so many actors i ended up later
working with were so rude i bet i bet do
you know who was the nicest
really he was the most because she
delicious uh uh girl next girl next door
yes in which i play that's right that
was your first like high school girl
number seven i bought weed from timothy
elephant i was gonna say how could molly
finn this great casting not look at you
oh just look at you she gave me chances
though i was terrible i like i i was i
was learning to audition and i remember
she told me she's like you've had too
much theater training like i was just
i had no idea no you did have theater
training i did but you know school like
nothing professional so she said you
were being too like kind of big
why are you speaking so clearly
because i had a real like slurry mumble
as a young person and i blame it on
being from dc there's a lot of like
slurry mumbling
wow it's just like
hey how you doing how's all hey and she
was like please get back to a natural
way of speaking because i had been then
trained to speak very very clearly
you're like what are you talking about
mali
this is just the natural way in which i
speak
but she used to tell us stories you know
at lunch it was all the assistants just
like tell us more mellie and she would
talk about sam rockwell first of all i
have to say she used him as the example
of like
how great actors can perform on the fly
like they're just so present and smart
and they can perform on the flight
so you never did that she would tell the
story
that sam came in to read for the green
mile and was given um material oh no
came in started reading the material and
it was the wrong material
and that they said oh sam you have the
wrong pages and he was like what oh no
oh no
and they're like it's okay here's a here
are the correct scenes do you want to
come back another day he's like i'll
just go learn it just give me like 30
minutes or an hour i'll just go learn it
and i'll come back and they were like
wow okay great we'll get some coffee i
was going to go no
i'll be right back so we came back and
crushed it yeah it was like incredible
and they were all like this oh he's the
savant this is the most incredible thing
and she would use that story to say like
good actors should be able to just a
cold read like that and be brilliant so
years later i become friends with sammy
and i tell him like man you were a
legend
at the office when i was 18 as a casting
assistant i told him the story and he's
like oh
yeah that was like a that was a trick i
used to play
get out of here he get the out he's
like yeah i knew that i knew the
material
i had spent years being like one day
i'll be like sam
or you can just learn seven pages in 20
minutes he's a con man oh no i used to
do that all the time exactly sorry i got
charlie's angels trick trick drew
that's so funny yeah she never and mali
passed away before i could tell her like
sam's a fraud it's a great trick it's a
great trip
i would fall for that as a director yeah
i'd be like we gotta cast this guy he
learned it in 20 minutes i guess i used
to do versions of that where i would
sometimes say like oh i just got these
you know yeah yeah uh my computer wasn't
working i tried to like lower the bar
for myself and they're like well he
wasn't very good but for someone who
just got them he was decent but she you
know i carried a lot of her lessons
actually into
making book smart like she had really
high standards
for actors which i which i love i mean
so many casting directors we both know
just couldn't care less they're like
eating a sandwich while they're filming
you
she was of an acting teacher before she
became a casting director i didn't know
that and and she believed everyone
should prepare and that she wanted
everyone to be off book
and so many actors not you because i
know how professional you are so many
actors would come in
and just be so lazy yeah and just
reading off the page yeah and she would
stop auditions and say i'm sorry why
don't you come back when you've done the
work wow oh my god and then i would have
to call people's agents oh my god hi i
was living in from allies i was just
gonna say uh if if she could come back
when she's done the work and then she
would also say like and tell them she
needs to eat and i'd be like hell so if
she could eat
that's a note i like that your
impression of subordinates in mali's
office sound like mickey mouse we did
kind of drunken mickey mouse
oh yeah
sorry
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
um cockburn oh yeah let's get into it it
was coburn
yeah um yeah this has been a secret yeah
this is no longer a secret um and so
when kids make fun would kids come we
should clarify because of the nature of
the name people might think you just
revealed some like medical issue that
i've suffered oh he's not suffering from
um although if you are suffering from
cockburn one of our sponsors is a great
salve for it
um
am i
both a self and a bomb that's why it's
such a great product i
changed my name when i was 18.
from coburn to wild okay and it's
pronounced coburn it's spelled
c-o-c-k-b-u-r-n which looks very clearly
like cockburn which was something that i
grew up
intimately familiar with they're really
friendly what
what you're intimately familiar with
now with hearing it
justin sorry we'll cut it i it's really
funny because i grew up going back and
forth between ireland and the states
right my dad's irish and in the uk as a
whole like it's a very common name and
and people would pronounce it coburn and
then when i'd go back to you know like
fifth grade olivia
yeah which i believe is a very important
thing you want to have you want to name
your kids something that's truly
embarrassing it's like boy named sue
right you really want to grow up with
something yes
bad to strengthen their characters it's
important it's important to be abused at
a young age that's what i'm saying
you're talking yes oh that's a good
message
and we'll just use
by your peers yeah
um but it's but i think a little bit of
that is important it's good for you my
uncle's name is dick long so my family's
no stranger to this who named him
richard here's the crazy thing he was
named john long and beautiful sounds
like an astronaut yeah yeah it kind of
dignified even yeah and i think either
my
grandma i think my grandmother was like
john i don't like that to richer because
my grandma is just not a good
but the point the point is he insisted
on going by not richard or rich or any
derivation of that dick
dick long i mean it's kind of great it
makes me love him immediately yeah i i
like it because it's fun to talk about
but at the time your parents aren't
probably like forecasting that cockburn
is gonna be an issue no because well to
be fair to my dad like he's not american
so he was like well everyone's going to
pronounce it coburn and that's the way
you pronounce it and then and then it is
a very um
a dignified name within the world of
journalism my grandfather was a very
famous journalist and a
activist in my uncles and my dad like
there's a there's a long line of of
impressive journalists so are they
disappointed that you haven't you're not
carrying on the name publicly anyway no
actually there's a bunch of pen names
within my family like my um
my father's half-sister has a she went
from uh codwell or
i forget what her original name was but
she changed it to codwell and then i my
grandfather went by helvik
but i thought it was kind of like
romantic to have like a numb de plume
like you have a a
pen name that makes you have a kind of
artistic identity
so the pretentious teenager in me was
like i want a pen name of sorts an
artistic name and then honestly what it
sounds so nerdy but i was i was doing a
lot of oscar wilde plays and i was i was
doing the importance of being earnest i
was playing gwendolyn i was like 16.
and it was the first time i really felt
like i crushed it on stage and i loved
doing the play and i was like this is
amazing so i read everything oscar wrote
i read everything about him
and i was like this is this is the
inspiration i want to carry with me so
it started in that very earnest place
totally if i did that i mine would be
justin simon because mine was neil simon
my first time i felt like i crashed was
yes was uh i i liked i didn't know that
that was where it came from and then and
then what's crazy is then so i i changed
it when i turned 18 i was like this is
going to be my my stage name
and then it very quickly became my name
like i want i'd be very curious to talk
to people like
jack black or natalie portman or
like woody allen about this like these
are all people who've that's true who've
chosen names yeah but once it's your
name longer than it wasn't your name
yeah you're kind of like this is this is
truly me like what does the name olivia
coburn even sound like to you it sounds
like like early childhood weird and um
of course the rest of my family sounds
like
oh that's of course so i i and i and
like for instance last year my mom ran
for congress in virginia yes and i
retweeted her stuff i think oh yeah it
didn't work she lost it
sorry mrs gilbert
but it was really interesting
going around and you know in rural
virginia hearing my mom tell people like
well it's pronounced coburn and i was
like how brave she's heading into the
like political landscape with a name
that is very tricky and actually
reminded me about hearing obama speak in
2007 and he was like listen guys my
first name rhymes with iraq
my middle name is literally hussein
and my last name rhymes with osama this
is not going to be easy and i was like
bless your heart it is incredible that
he that nut he overcame that just that
it just that i know that's what people
thought like he is talk about like
electability and now that being this
kind of
dumb issue that we deal with now he was
completely unelectable because of the
name like forget about the race issue
which was like huge yeah
beyond that the name god and i don't
think people appreciate how bad the name
hussein was that's right it's because
now it's like
yeah now there's tons of hussains
exactly um yeah yeah it was do you have
you had anything to do with him do you
talk to him ever do you have to bump
into him
he i mean now that he's in our business
it feels funny it's like oh yeah now you
come over to our world yeah interesting
yeah um of course they are making like
the most incredible content and i love
that they're working with netflix and it
sounds like they're just picking up all
the greatest things i think they're
pilots going to get picked up i think
i just want to talk about politics yeah
about your involvement in politics
because that's how i met you yes in 2008
oh my god that's crazy how involved are
you now uh in in politics and and what
brought you to that campaign how did you
get involved okay so
i grew up in dc
and they're it's less true now because
of the internet and everything but as a
kid in dc i feel that you grow up with a
little bit more of a
organic connection to the political
process maybe because it's just directly
related to lifestyle there i mean yeah
with each administration new people move
into the city new kids at school like it
changes the vibe so and your parents
weren't your your parents did uh
impressive things you're they were
journalists they still are okay um
and so they were not connected to
politics in in a kind of
a typical way they were i mean obviously
they're
investigative journalists and war
correspondents so it was connected to to
the political process but i didn't feel
like
connected to an administration but i
felt growing up in dc maybe because my
parents were very
informed and they expect us expected us
and still do to be very informed and so
i grew up with a sense of it being a big
part of my life and actually it's funny
because when i was a teenager and i was
like into politics
that was considered
kind of lame
and now you're a model um yeah yeah
political awareness club you're looking
at the vice president of course of the
fairfield prep political awareness that
makes total sense and only cool kids in
my school did it
right
um that's what they told you but now
like it truly is much cooler and i think
it's because
of the political situation we've put
them in that young people are like yes
all right all right well let's fully
take it you guys are fired what have you
guys done
but i think so long story short i i i
was i came to this town in this industry
already pretty um passionate about
politics and i kind of looked for a
community here of people who were who
were like-minded in that way yeah and
i learned about barack obama in like
early early 2007 when he came to la to
do
yes
and i
went to this talk and there were like 40
people in the basement of the beverly
hilton and
kidnapped uh we were all tied to a chair
one chair one chair 40 people lots of
rope and we were so inspired by him and
of course you can imagine what it was
like so therefore i was on board
immediately and i was like a hell of a
basement
one of the best basements i've ever been
to very good it's not great i'm working
it's been a while he's been out of it
yeah i know thanks but but so i jumped
on board and then started being a
surrogate and surrogate leader and
trying to get other people involved and
of course tons of people were
immediately involved and then we got to
go on these really fun trips around the
country and that
was a very exciting time it was a really
cool thing to be a part of it was and
and i i don't know if it'll ever feel
like that again i mean now actually
we're back at that place where we are
really looking for somebody yeah too
when you break the mold you got me
involved and and then that i
transitioned into like doing stuff with
similar things with bernie uh yeah
but um but it was it was just fun and it
felt exciting it felt like such an
exciting time to be
a part of that world because everyone
felt essential and then
we were seeing the birth of this
incredible volunteer network across the
country that was actually using social
media smartly for the first time and it
was exciting to go and speak to those
student leaders who were being so
effective with their networks yeah and
you got me on to twitter i mean oh my
gosh you you got me on twitter and uh
you're welcome world yes yeah and you
are one of the few people who i think
use it really effectively uh we're gonna
be talking to roger mcnamee in a couple
weeks yeah so uh that's cool it's very
cool yeah so we've been reading uh about
his work and and
and all of the pitfalls that come along
with this platform but you use it in a
very responsible way do you
do you feel that that sense of
responsibility and and how do you use it
i mean how does it fit in your life i
got on twitter because of the arab
spring that sounds insane but i remember
reading that people are organizing
movements on twitter and i was like well
that's really cool and i was trying to
raise money for an organization in haiti
for a hospital in haiti and so i thought
wait we can raise money really quickly
using twitter that's right guys she's
charitable too
right
i was a much better person then
now i'm i'm much lazier i blame my
children but i i was i was excited about
the potential of communicating with a
lot of people at once
and also frankly
and now this this is now very normal but
at the time it felt kind of new
to for people in the spotlight to
establish their own voices for
themselves like twitter really changed
the way that consumers audiences
understood who
we were aside from like what a studio
that's right sanctioned press piece
would be it was like this is my voice
yeah and i remember people saying to me
well you know you're a lot like people
would be like you're funny i didn't
think you were funny and i was like god
that's sad but i get it you know and
what's sad and i'm your friend and i can
admit this i didn't know you were funny
i didn't know you were funny until i met
you and i was like how was this i just
assumed you weren't because you were so
beautiful i was like this doesn't that's
just doesn't align we're all guilty of
doing that to each other yeah i'm not
proud of it i i just um and then i
remember sammy when sam when you worked
with sam cowboys and aliens he would
call me and go
i i was i would get so frustrated
because you go hey man you got to meet
olivia sam is the worst memory and i got
i know olivia leave he's my my friend
and he was like you got to come out here
she's funny man she's funny she's cool
and i was like i know i knew
before i knew um and now everybody knows
and i'm happy they do it also like i
knew back then it's actually but that
that speaks to you know that like that's
funny because the themes of booksmart
being about high school and like how we
categorize each other in high school it
was just a direct reflection of how this
business works and how we do that to
each other we put each other in boxes
and i'm still guilty of it i'll look at
someone and be like there's no way that
person's smart what are you talking
about yeah and then i'll read something
they wrote be like goddamn i know how
did that happen i know people always
assume i'm not a great athlete oh right
um
but but you uh so to so twitter and bull
it must have been a tool that you
embraced
it was even though i was the last person
to understand the concept because i
remember being at a a party
at uh it was like an agency party some
like terrible party and these two guys
came up to me they're like we have this
platform that we're launching it's
called twitter
and they ran down the concept and i was
like okay
let me get this straight
so it's a website a sort of a web page
where people post a sentence
i don't know guys uh yeah
try again
this is not gonna take off you probably
thought they were just like hitting on
you i i didn't i was just like that's a
terrible idea yeah and then i did the
same thing for conversations about i'm
not proud of this airbnb and uber i was
like guys let me tell you something
it's not gonna work anytime you wanna
ride you no no no no no um well okay so
i won't be taking your like investment
advice don't i've missed so many
[Music]
do you ever get insecure oh my god yes
well i know that
why do you know that what are you saying
well we're friends
no i'm insecure no but no absolutely and
my my thing is like if i'm working on
something i'm very good at plugging into
it completely and i really invest a lot
of myself into it in every way yeah my
trouble area is the is the in-between
moment like
right now trying to figure out what to
direct next i'm like i just feel like
i'm this like
sea creature just floating around the
bottom of the ocean just looking for
something so you want to tether yourself
to this exactly
and once i do
yeah just reading everything and
thinking like what can i love as much as
i love this but
the the other thing about that is i
think what
was difficult for me and because i don't
want to stop acting what's difficult to
me about acting sometimes
is the kind of on the rhythm of an
actor's experience on a set is so
inconsistent
like i love the collaboration of of
making movies and telling stories but
for actors it's like okay
you come on after the work has started
you come in you walk on set
you have like a very short period of
time to kind of plug in and be creative
then you're asked to leave then you come
back do it for a second then you're
asked to leave i mean it's just like on
off on off and that's exhausting i'd
much rather work consistently for 18
hours totally then
spend four hours
total in a trailer yeah wondering if
you're gonna go back and act especially
on those big jobs yeah it can a whole
day you can i mean oh god it's going to
pass just if you're working with certain
people who
don't want to
show up to set
um sometimes hours uh but you have so
many others
as good of an actress as you are i i
don't
think of you i mean i think of you as my
friend but i i also don't in terms of
your profession i it's hard for me to
think of you as an actress because
you are so curious and have such a great
mind and and i guess that sounds sort of
like insulting
no i know what you're saying and the
capacity in which i met you would have
nothing to do with that that's true and
i but i don't know if i would give like
i always had felt weird yeah that fire
dancing
ritual but i
i don't know if i ever felt totally
comfortable
saying i was and i always feel a little
bit of shame like i'm an actress i'm
sorry why is that i know i know
it's weird like the other day otis who's
five now oh this is your oldest he's my
oldest daisy's two and a half otis is
five i said to him otis do you know what
i do because you never know if your kids
know what you do and he's like yeah mom
you're a director and it was the first
time
i believed that and i was like whoa
whoa would you would you say that again
say it again into the mic otis why are
you shaking me mommy
why are you crying
but i don't know like i think the cool
thing about this industry though is
honestly you don't even have to he came
on set and and
destroyed lots of takes being loud but i
i feel like
the cool thing about this industry is
you are encouraged or at least it is
permitted if you have the will
to to do several different things like
to have several different roles within
the storytelling process like i've been
producing stuff for years you can be an
actor a director a producer a writer and
there's no real like firewall in between
each role
it's fluid in a way yeah and that's
something that's very cool about the
industry you think about other
industries and it's like just a little
trickier to do that and i think
sometimes people don't take advantage of
it of the ability to hop around i think
as you get older
i mean you're also getting not giving
yourself credit some i don't know that a
lot of people have what you have and
have the capacity to do all those things
well maybe it's like
i don't know if i ever felt
good enough
as an actress that i was i could settle
yeah i was like there's something about
this that i don't like yeah i um so i
just kept searching well that's the fun
thing about this is that you get to be
creative and it's i have all the things
that i enjoy from acting but it's
without all the without a lot of the
you mean podcasting yeah just
talking to somebody and having a
conversation it's the best so you had
always wanted to be an actress you i
mean when you were in high school yeah
and even younger i mean i was from the
three
right that was it were you agree like a
performancy kid yeah it was a real ham
all right well my sister was super
super smart from a young age and so she
was like older sister older sisters five
years older and she was just like
really impressive she was also really
tall from a young age so she was she got
a lot of attention
and so i had to fight for attention by
being like
me yeah and i see it now with my kids oh
yeah daisy is a ham and she's so i mean
otis is like
he's kind of like brooding and
like just sort of more stoic he's more
stoic and quiet and brooding and just
kind of like sits in the corner staring
off into space and like humming and he
like makes beats on garageband yeah and
he's really into drama it does he draws
still into drumming
and daisy's a little more like let me
make you laugh she's like doing
pratfalls all day long so it was very
similar for me and then that turned into
me
realizing that acting was a way to be a
ham professionally yeah and and then i
i really went all in from a young age
like it it was my focus forever
and well it's i mean it paid off so you
never thought about doing anything else
you never thought with you i just i i'm
still up on your mind how good your
mouth fertile your mind is do you ever
think about i mean your mom ended up
doing it do you think she's gonna run
again would you ever consider that
i don't think i could do it i don't
think i have the heart for it i don't
think i have the energy or the patience
for it i'm also terrible at like i just
open my mouth way too much and say
things i shouldn't well that's the thing
how do you do that's because you are
active on twitter i mean and people look
to you as a source of
you know wisdom now when it comes to
political things and and your opinion
really matters you know what's
interesting
that i've noticed like like for
celebrities talking about politics 10
years ago
at least but really around 10 years ago
it was thought of as being super
dangerous like remember when it was like
uh i don't know if you should talk about
politics like it was very much like shut
up and dribble it was like our version
of shut up and dribble totally and now
it's like if you don't have a political
opinion
you're kind of a pariah that's true it's
flipped and so while i think you know i
do love to share information it's so
comforting to see that that's very
normal now that everybody's like here
read these articles inform yourself like
this is something we're all a part of
you know seeing um busy phillips talk
about her abortion on her show was
amazing because like that is so
mainstream and it's so powerful but
you're right 10 years ago that would
that would be on she would have been
told yeah not to do it and
i so i think at this point it's it's
transformed i think it's because we're
in a total national crisis and like
we're all going to die very very soon so
we have to try everything we can well on
that note um thanks so much for being no
no i i just want to know if you um i
i would definitely campaign for you i
hope you you know that i would be
terrible no i i would be the worst
representative i wouldn't be good but i
think i'll just direct content for your
campaign um
you
i would you know i went to beanie's
bat mitzvah what yeah i went to beanie's
butt mitzvah because joan and i were
very close friends and um it was it was
such a fun night and i know beanie well
and i and i've she's
perfect for this part uh yes but the
part is
at least in the beginning of the movie
there's something tracy flick about this
character there's something uh something
that beanie or any performer and
director has to overcome that's right a
certain like unlikability which
particularly for women
is something that can be very very scary
because there's a tendency to pigeonhole
quote-unquote unlikable women as being
permanently unlikable yes how does is
that
beanie how do you
handle that well i mean and why
handicapped the the character it was
that important to show her in terms of
showing her growth yes it was all about
growth i knew that we wanted
to have kind of the the sharpest arc for
that character in terms of
her mind opening to accept others that
you would assume that as the
two incredibly smart political
intellectual hard-working feminists in
the school that they would be the ones
who kind of weren't accepted and yet
it's a story of two girls who
sort of assume that's the case and then
realize that they haven't really been
able to see others and particularly
being these characters so i've never
seen that before i thought that was a
really idea because that's all of our
experience like you think about what's
like we're talking about the need for
empathy yes how do you
how do you overcome some of these
obstacles we're all facing in in the
political club and i think it is
acknowledging the universal human
qualities and really allowing for
complexity and nuance in other human
beings and in yourself
so i wanted her character to start in
such a tightly wound guarded place that
we could witness the unwinding
uh we got to do rapid fire we're not
good at rapid fire anything
i know have you been listening to this
uh and by the way feel free to expound
um what's your most commonly used emoji
the drool face oh really yeah it's like
it's kind of like it's kind of obscene
but it works for everything it's a
second answer um
if you could be that's really funny if
you could be a professional athlete what
what sport would you play basketball you
love basketball but i don't want to be
in the wnba sorry i want to be in the
nba okay the nets
well i do yes i mean
i love the nets i love the oklahoma city
thunder i love the clippers and i love
golden state whoa but i'm really proud
of the nets it's really exciting to have
the nets doing so well i mean for a
couple years there it was just really
easy to get nets tickets yeah yeah i
know selfishly it's not i know uh i know
i root for the knicks but really
selfishly love the next that's the thing
i do there's nothing like going to msg
and sitting there and what i remember
the last time
we when we still lived in chelsea we
went to almost an entire season of
knicks games we must have been so
unemployed like why were we so available
yeah but we went so often that we became
those superstitious fans who like
wouldn't change clothes if they won a
playoff game yeah like i was really all
in and that was it those those were good
times but it's been a while since the
knicks were in the playoffs um
snack food what's your favorite snack
food
if you could have one for the rest of
your life what yeah oh
it's sword
one snack food or the rest of my there's
gonna be something salty i'm a savory
person
you are you know you're really good food
you know what it is
it's
terrible barbecue chips
that's not terrible
it's kind of gross no they're delicious
yeah but there's kind of like
like you never want to be like
like close confines with someone who's
eating barbecue chips like if i had them
right now
i'd be covered in the dust that's the
dust it's that orange and then do you
see when i don't suck it off see before
i when i was a kid and nothing mattered
and like they're not the carbs or like
yeah after all that health health i
didn't have anything that yeah
yeah and you lick your face you lick
your fingers after you've been touching
everything it's a terrible yeah it's a
terrible thing i didn't grow once who
turned me on who who made me realize how
um
potentially disgusting eating popcorn in
a movie theater was which i still do
she had a thing about it and she was so
easygoing about
everything else but she was like
popcorn i hate that and i said why she's
like a little rat just like
and she imitated me eating it and i was
like well there he goes that she trained
it for you there goes yeah for a while i
still do it and now i do okay favorite
movie of all time oh my goodness sorry i
know these are these are big okay these
aren't wrapped um i think lebowski yeah
oh
yeah makes sense uh if you could have
dinner with three people dead or alive
who you whom you've never met okay
okay i got it i got him into it i got
this or who you half men you just don't
really know
okay okay okay okay oh oliver sacks i'm
a big neuro nerd i love
i love
like and like i just love if i could go
to school back to school i didn't go to
college right so if i could go to
college now i would study
neuroscience
i love
you know um everything having to do with
with like sociological analysis based on
neurological studies and and and
oliver sacks i mean he became famous for
a man who mistook his wife for a hat but
all his anthologies for a hat
you have to read that story and all the
rest of his books
um awakenings was the one that was
turned into a film but that's why i know
it
the man who mistook his wife for a hat
is truly one of the most fascinating
stories um
but he's just he's the best so i would
say all of her sacks he passed away but
he would be one
he can come
um
harvey milk is someone i've been
thinking about a lot recently in terms
of like his attitude towards activism
was about empathy it wasn't about
sort of um you know pity and civil
rights being an issue that you feel
obligated to care about because you pity
another group of people he was all about
like acknowledging that we are all one
so when you think about for instance
like reproductive rights now i always
think you know the way harvey milk would
approach the issue of abortion is for
everyone who's had an abortion to talk
about their abortion totally for
everybody to realize this is part of our
lives as opposed to like feel bad for
those women yeah pity them that's why
what bizzy said the other day was really
important i think yes and she encouraged
everyone women to start talking about it
yes that's what will make the difference
i grew up catholic so it was a thing
that people did not really talk about um
but i think that you're i think you're
right uh okay so i have oliver and
harvey but i feel bad about not having a
woman on there so i'm just gonna well
you'll be there i'll be there and then
maybe like janice joplin just because i
feel like she'll bring that wild turkey
oh yeah
yeah she might make it difficult to talk
to oliver and but um
uh you know how we i was just thinking
about that sketch on portlandia where
they're like i'm a nerd it was pretty
girls it's the psa about not calling
yourself a nerd yeah you're really not a
nerd who's your favorite muppet
um ralph oh yeah yeah he plays piano
yeah he's a good time he's a good time
charlie yeah we're all yeah um if you
could have super x-ray vision or super
hearing which would you choose
oh
oh god i think super hearing
i
i don't need to see through things
it's all right
i don't need to see
the one problem is am i able to turn it
off because i don't always want to go
can they can you turn it off no oh never
mind i i opt out i don't want either um
yeah you're right if you were stuck with
super hearing
you hear every little thing that oh shut
up sometimes i'm at uh i mean sometimes
it's fun when you're at a restaurant
you're like eavesdropping yeah yeah but
get old real fast it's true and you're
right x-ray vision would also get a
little like problem i don't want to see
that most people i don't want to see
naked
um uh if you could be one age age for
the rest of your life what would you
want
physically physically yeah oh physically
i guess like 24. okay you're just like
nothing in here no years
is that what you did no i was like 19
when i did it
beetle stones
oh
oh it's that hard that's really hard for
me because they're both invaluable there
is not one without the other it is the
perfect combo i'm gonna say well here's
the thing here's what i'm gonna say this
is a long answer i can't you kept the
dress wait
the stones are obviously derivative of
like american blues right
and so it's not like they invented
a sound we're gonna need an answer
miss coburn
okay i'm gonna say stones
okay sorry um
sorry beetles
uh they'll be fine
uh i
i the word i people in this business say
love too often yes but i love you i love
you i love you and i'm i'm so grateful
that you did this is that how you wrap
up everything no yeah yeah that's my
that's my sign off cause i'll be
heartbroken if i listen and i'm like
goddamn it just yeah i just said that to
ace freely everyone needs to see
book smart it is out
may 24th may 24th
everywhere go see it go see it and bring
your friends
well well so that happened
oh god it's so sticking uh
i did happen i sarcastically said that
on our first episode and i meant it as a
joke because i'm sort of i get irritated
by i don't like when people say that i
find it kind of annoying yeah what are
the other things you're annoyed by but
now i've now i feel like we're stuck
with it so uh now it's something that's
happening now it's the name of the
segment
so this is currently happening
i guess people can write in and say if
they really hate it and we can stop
doing it that was really interesting
when she talked about her more socialist
approach to filmmaking where everyone is
important and everyone has a voice i
thought that was so cool totally you
know the closest i've seen to that that
when i when i've been on sets is um
two of the best directors i've worked
with sam raymond kevin smith both employ
a version of that communal
aspect like sam for example called he
asks everyone's opinion he'll ask the
opinion of the pa who's getting an actor
coffee or
a grip who's moving equipment around hey
guys sir what do you what do you think
of it you know he wants everybody's
very collaborative and and kevin
similarly kevin um
makes the he gives this great speech
before every day of filming which is
basically we're all doing this thing
together i'm excited that you guys are
here like it's cool it must make for
such a
great atmosphere it does that
collaborative yeah
she compared it to doing a play where
you know in theater it's totally it's so
much more of a of a team
environment right when you do a play
whereas on film sets it can often be the
actors wait their trailer and they come
out when they're called for and they're
treated and the crew is very different
than the cast yeah there's more of a
hierarchy but it sounds like on her set
it was
that wasn't the case which i thought was
really cool yeah and then it becomes
like everyone is stepping up a little
bit more i mean even if it's even if
it's like subconscious on a subconscious
level you're just
trying that much harder when you feel
like you're a more integral part of
something and
that to me is how every set should be
but it's surprising how few are like
that you know when i first met her i
remember thinking that she presents this
like very regal
image and she and she stands up straight
and she is you know obviously beautiful
and she carries herself
like someone who is from
noble
birth yes you know she has a very and
come to find out she actually does i
mean it makes sense because she her
ancestry is like
full of impressive
influential people so she is in fact
yeah noble birth uh but she's also an
incredibly good hang i remember when i
first met her and of course i had had
preconceived notions about her because
of her you know because of her beauty
because of what you're talking about and
and and it's such a unique beauty like
uh almost like almost alien almost
like elf
yeah she reminded me a lot of valve
oh
and she eats cats and she's always
getting into trouble i was also happy to
adhere that she's not good at something
investing in tech she thought uber and
twitter were bad ideas
thank god thank god there's something
wrong with something i know i know it's
not a huge thing no but it's it's
something god was like ah man i gotta
i've given her so many things her nba
affiliations are all over the map she
was she was like i'm a huge nba fan i
love the knicks oh yeah and the lakers
and the golden state warriors and the
oklahoma city thunder it's like yeah you
can't love all these teams right well
you can love someone but like the one
that threw me was the knicks and the
nets that's gonna
upset some sports it's gonna be a
controversial
yeah that's gonna be a sound bite
also i we brought up with her afterwards
um the similarities between this book
smart and and super bad which i felt
there were
a couple the first one that i noticed in
the movie was when they you meet the two
characters together when one character
goes to pick up the other and we brought
that up with olivia and she was like i
was like i love that homage to superbad
and she was like um not really
i don't know what you're talking about
uh well just because one character is
picking up another in a car yeah and i
was like oh yeah i feel dumb well it's
it's also
yeah they're jonah's sister is yeah you
know we've known beanie since she was
this you know before she was a woman we
saw beanie become a woman and she's
always been the most fun loving dynamic
kid you know life moves pretty fast it's
crazy to see her be that dynamic uh
adult now on screen and olivia captured
it so well um it's just great
performances it's a great movie i i'm
sorry if i ruined it for anyone but
[Music]
thank you for listening to life is short
if you like the show please give us a
five star review please tell your
friends to subscribe and your frenemies
we're available on apple podcast spotify
google podcasts and every major
listening app as well as wondery.com
life is short is hosted by me justin
long produced by christian long and
megan monaco senior producer is michelle
lanz executive produced by marsha louis
and ernan lopez for wondering
[Music]
yeah yeah you nailed it
but that's not corny that's more like
regressing to your like my t
my maybe i'm regressing you're stuff
like that's how we used to talk we'd be
like radical awesome
why would i be regressing
um
i'm not a psychologist well maybe but i
imagine it would have something to do
with
like not that you're scared of getting
older yeah so psychologically oh my god
against that by
younger oh my god but i don't know what
i'm talking about oh that's scary
you